[Musique]
et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Sophie Hoffman bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
journaliste en devenir autrice du
podcast my boobs story littéralement
l'histoire de mon sein un podcast en 200
épisodes de 5 minutes chacun dans lequel
vous racontez votre cancer du sein au
quotidien et le parcours votre combat
contre la maladie c'était il y a deux
ans à l'automne 2020 vous aviez 34 ans
et on vous a diagnostiqué un cancer au
sein droit de façon très précoce et pour
cause vous étiez surveillé de près oui
voilà en fait moi ce qui se passe c'est
que j'ai une mutation sur le gène BRCA1
donc c'est un gène dont on est tous
porteurs homme et femme et chez
certaines personnes il est muté donc il
a une anomalie et en fait quand on a
cette anomalie et que se développe un
cancer au niveau du sein ou de l'ovaire
l'organisme ne s'est pas réparé donc
c'est pour ça que moi bon ça s'est
déclaré à 34 ans ça aurait pu se passer
un petit peu plus tard
mais l'objectif de ce suivi très très
régulier c'était de pouvoir intervenir
au tout début de la formation de ce de
ce cancer alors vous étiez suivi à
l'Institut currique un des instituts en
pointe ici en France de la recherche et
du traitement du cancer vous ce n'était
pas nécessairement une surprise vous
saviez que vous étiez à risque on n'est
pas nécessairement préparé pour autant
qu'est-ce qu'on se dit quand on est
diagnostic on se dit à mince je pensais
pas que on sait que ça peut arriver
c'est vraiment quand on est porteuse de
cette mutation ou porteur d'ailleurs ce
que c'est ça arrive chez les hommes
aussi
on sait que ça peut arriver mais moi en
plus j'étais dans un projet de grossesse
donc j'étais pas du tout là dedans je
m'étais dit bon ça fait un an que j'ai
pas fait ces examens de dépistage donc
il faut absolument que je le fasse et
j'ai bien fait
mais voilà le choc est quand même là en
plus voilà on prononce des mots qui font
peur mastectomie chimiothérapie
radiothérapie on arrive dans un enfin
voilà dans tout un lexique qu'on a
jamais envie d'entendre et puis après
bon bah ça se fait en fait et tout de
suite on est quoi on est combatif où on
est mu par la nécessité de se dire bon
bah de toute façon combattif ou
courageux ou pas il faut y aller ouais
on y va je pense que c'est vraiment on
est dans un espèce de tunnel où on va
tracer on se dit ok l'objectif c'est les
traitements donc on va y aller à fond
moi j'ai essayé de voilà d'aborder ça de
la façon la plus positive possible
en me disant bon bah c'est un c'est un
passage ça va être un moment de ma vie
et je vais le traverser voilà le mieux
possible voilà et votre façon à vous de
faire face c'est que vous vous dites
tout de suite que vous allez peut-être
d'abord pour vous-même raconter avec
votre téléphone en enregistrant des
notes vocales tout ce qui va se passer
dans les mois qui sont devant vous un
journal de bord
optimiste pourquoi optimiste oui alors
cette idée c'est Damien mon conjoint en
fait qui me l'a soufflé il m'a dit qu'au
début je prenais un petit peu des notes
vocales comme des post-it il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'informations
donc je commençais à enregistrer comme
ça boire tant de litres d'eau etc avant
elle examen et donc Damien m'a dit mais
enregistre en fait tes ressentis ce qui
se passe on a besoin de communiquer sur
cette maladie de transmettre vraiment la
réalité d'un parcours et c'est vrai que
finalement ce téléphone ça a été un
petit peu mon premier confident parce
que j'avais la possibilité de raconter
sur le vif ce qui était en train de se
passer quoi alors vous racontez tout les
chimio les radios la perte de vos
cheveux votre première mastectomie la
seconde qui a été préventive celle-là
pour le coup les bons moments les moins
bons vous entend rire et pleurer vous
avez eu autant besoin de comprendre ce
qui vous arrivez que que de l'expliquer
je pense à un épisode notamment vous
faites une petite note vocale à vos
proches pour leur expliquer ce qui va
vous arriver mais aussi la façon dont
vous avez envie qu'il vous en parle et
qu'il vous entourent parce que dans la
maladie il faut aussi gérer ça ouais en
fait j'avais pas envie enfin l'annonce a
été très travaillé entre guillemets je
me suis dit bon il faut que ce soit très
clair que j'annonce les faits et que je
dise effectivement ce que je veux et ce
que je ne veux pas donc je ne veux pas
entendre par exemple bah oui bah j'ai eu
telle personne dans mon entourage qui a
été touchée par cette maladie et ça
s'est mal fini ça on n'a pas besoin de
le savoir même si les gens ont besoin en
fait de voilà de le dire parce que s'il
y a ça fait face à beaucoup de peur
aussi
et voilà j'ai dit si vous voulez m'aider
et ben allez demander des échantillons
de crème du vernis des choses qui vont
mettre utiles en fait j'ai eu besoin de
guider comme ça
alors parmi les choses qui ne vous ont
pas aidé donc peut-être ces récits de
gens qui vous racontent des histoires
terribles qu'est-ce qui n'aide pas non
plus dans ces moments-là je pense le
changement de regard en fait c'est vrai
que nous on n'a pas envie de changer on
n'a pas on n'a pas envie qu'on nous
parle il fait différemment on n'a pas
envie qu'on nous parle plus de telles
choses ou de telles choses des petites
tracas ouais c'est ça en fait parce que
ça fait partie du quotidien de chacun et
je vois pas pourquoi oui bien sûr par
rapport à ce qu'on est en train de vivre
c'est c'est rien entre guillemets mais
c'est quand même le quotidien donc il
faut continuer à partager comme on le
faisait auparavant avec cette personne
quoi et alors à contrario qu'est-ce qui
aide dans ces moments là quelle parole
ou quel justement est-ce que vous pouvez
nous conseiller des d'autres récits qui
vous ont pu vous aider je pense que
l'écoute si voilà si on est à même de
recueillir la parole il faut pas hésiter
à le signaler et après des choses très
concrètes ma mère m'a beaucoup aidé sur
les draps par exemple ça paraît tout
bête mais elle les prenait elle elle
l'avait et il revenait tout propre donc
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose d'utile
si c'est une personne qui a des enfants
embarqué les enfants pour une après-midi
ou ramener des plats par exemple enfin
des choses très concrètes qui vont aider
la personne qui vit la maladie et la
personne aussi qui soutient parce que
c'est vraiment des choses concrètes et
utiles la maladie vient un bouleverser
le rapport
au corps au cœur aussi est-ce que et
vous vous confiez beaucoup dans ce
podcast vos rapports à vos cheveux à vos
sourcils qui tombent assez sains bien
sûr qui ne sont plus tout à fait les
mêmes non plus tout à fait différents
mais voilà qui viennent bien sûr être
bouleversés est-ce que le fait que ces
dernières années il y a eu beaucoup de
choses sur ce rapport au corps que des
tabous soient tombés ça permet de vivre
les choses peut-être avec moins de
difficultés oui et puis le fait que la
chirurgie reconstructrice évolue aussi
énormément moi ma chirurgienne donc m'a
annoncé tout de suite qu'elle
préconisait une mastectomie même si
c'était pas obligatoire vu que la tumeur
était petite mais avec le BRCA1 le la
mutation il y a quand même des grands
risques et elle m'a dit mais la
reconstruction sera immédiate donc c'est
pas toujours le cas mais vous vous
endormez avec un sein et vous vous
réveillez avec un sein et ma soeur
m'avait dit mais cette phrase est très
dure mais oui mais en même temps moi
c'est quelque chose qui m'a rassuré où
je me suis dit bon bah il y aura pas de
d'inconnu en fait ce sera pas exactement
le même saint mais ça restera un sein
comme moi je le connais quoi dans un
épisode vous dites que un des derniers
je crois que vous serez marqué à vie
dans votre corps bien sûr mais comment
est-ce que ça se traduit dans la tête
est-ce qu'on devient
plus forte oui je pense ouais ouais je
pense qu'on devient plus forte on se dit
bon bah j'ai traversé ça donc
ouais voilà ou alors tout enfin toutes
les autres choses c'est du bonus quoi
c'est du c'est des choses positives je
dis souvent aussi qu'il faut profiter
quand ça va bien parce que quand on
voilà quand on a des chimios ou des
traitements on est un peu enfin le corps
il encaisse et du coup on a un petit peu
plus de mal sur certaines choses et
c'est vrai que quand on se lève et ça va
bien on peut marcher on peut courir on
respire normalement bah c'est bien aussi
de se dire que que ça va
je vous ai entendu dire que vous avez
réalisé après coup donc ce vous avez
diagnostiqué en 2020 en gros votre
traitement pour un petit cancer vous
dites était quand même un traitement
lourd vous avez fait plusieurs dizaines
de chimio et de radio a duré à peu près
un an et vous avez commencé le podcast
une fois que vous aviez fini voilà votre
parcours de soins corrigez-moi si je
compte mais vous n'avez compris qu'en
faisant le podcast à quel point ce qui
vous est arrivé était en fait
extrêmement dur oui il y a vraiment il y
a vraiment plusieurs temps je pense que
le cerveau il fonce et il se dit bon là
on réfléchit pas trop à ce qui se passe
et après c'est vrai que beaucoup de
femmes parlent de l'après cancer et se
trouve un petit peu délaissé mais c'est
vrai que c'est là où on se dit ah ouais
il s'est passé quand même tout ça j'ai
vécu tout ça enfin j'ai j'ai eu des gros
traitements de la chimiothérapie je l'ai
vécu en fait il y a vraiment un espèce
de décalage qui vient dans un second
temps ça c'est vrai ouais et peut-être
vous pas pour rentrer dans votre
intimité mais vous parliez tout à
l'heure de vos projets de grossesse
peut-être il faut dire aux gens qui nous
écoutent que avoir une mastectomie
n'empêche pas évidemment
d'avoir de partir ensuite sur une un
projet de grossesse voilà on peut avoir
un proche grossesse alors après
l'allaitement du coup n'est plus
possible vu qu'il y a plus de glandes
mammaires mais ce qui se passe c'est que
quand on n'a pas encore eu d'enfant et
que on a une des traitements comme la
chimiothérapie qui
en fait la fertilité il y a une
préservation de fertilité donc on va
congeler des ovotites c'est ce qui m'est
arrivé et ça c'est de plus en plus
proposer et il faut vraiment pas hésiter
à le demander si c'est pas le cas ce
qu'il ne faut pas hésiter non plus et
c'est l'occasion de le rappeler c'est de
se faire dépister on va peut-être
rappeler à quel âge il faut le faire et
comment oui alors c'est donc le
dépistage par mammographie c'est à
partir de 50 ans et il faut vraiment le
faire parce que en fait je sais que ça
fait peur mais c'est en arrivant au tout
début qu'on a le plus de chances de
guérir cette maladie et moi ce que je
conseille c'est par exemple de le faire
pourquoi pas entre copines ou avec sa
fille ou sa je sais pas sa nièce et de
se prendre un petit temps en même temps
c'est à dire de se faire un salon de thé
une virée shopping ou quelque chose
comme ça pour que le jour de la
mammographie se soit pas qu'une
contrainte voilà ici en France c'est
pris en charge gratuitement à partir de
50 ans on peut aussi pratiquer des
autopalpation se rendre une fois par an
avant 50 ans chez son gynécologue je
crois que pour les palpations il y a
beaucoup de vidéos qui permettent de se
le faire soi-même au rappel que 90% des
femmes atteintes d'un cancer sont guéris
vous vous êtes en rémission merci
beaucoup d'être venu nous raconter cette
histoire et donc my boobs story votre
podcast et trouvable sur toutes les
plateformes partout disponibles et
gratuit merci infiniment Sophie Hoffman
j'espère à bientôt dans notre belle
profession oui j'espère aussi et bonne
journée à vous merci encore infiniment
la suite de Paris direct c'est dans un
instant avec Sandrine Gomez à tout de
suite